[Musik]
sind
hallo
april kamen so sell it welt heute machen
wir ein favorit sandwich mit chicken
teriyaki weil so ist die kundschaft
gelobt diesem ihrem 85
das haben wir schon gezeigt genau und
ich mag am liebsten so sieht unser
chicken teriyaki aus ich habe ich gerade
das sandwich brot frisch gebacken
das heißt man muss sagen darf gut dieses
chicken teriyaki zu bereiten
das ist dann einfach hähnchen in einer
richtig würzig leckere soße und später
war von jeder seinen fans zu belegen wie
er möchte
also die brötchen oder besser gesagt die
brote solltet ihr vorbereitet haben und
dann euch direkt ans werk machen mit dem
schicken
deswegen zeigen ich jetzt einfach mal
die zutaten für die chicken teriyaki und
kohle stollen partner das ist so hinrich
von general meeting da greift die
gitarre wieder unseren jahren am tisch
und um das fußballschauen bruders sucht
wir frauen haben andere themen täter
stammt viele hater bittet nicht mein
video gibt mir keinen daumen herunter
nur wegen murat ich bin absolut also ich
gucke alles vom spiel ist alles und lief
alles fluggerät mich jetzt nicht weiter
auf sondern ich sage ich mal kurz die
zutaten für die soße brauche es noch im
vorjahr auf 4 ist little boots fischer
bloss sechs esslöffel essig ist ein
apfel etlichen reichlich geht aber zum
beispiel auch künstler chronik drei
esslöffel tomatenmark zwei erste klassen
denn hier habe ich ein stück ingwer und
knoblauch
hier habe ich ein paar ihnen filets vom
hündchen vier esslöffel öl und zwei
esslöffel stecke ich mach das zuerst
einmal die terrier aktive und stoffe
nämlich ist einfach die bestandteile
das heißt sojasauce sie bringt die
würfel mit rein seine fuß geschossen
das ist eine klassische englische wird
so sind die gibt's auch schon fertig zu
kaufen gibt verschiedene hersteller von
daher findet ihr bestimmt was in eurem
supermarkt es sich der honig platonisch
könnte man zum beispiel auch frauen und
zucker nehmen ab da könnt ihr selbst
entscheiden
was wir gerne nehmen möchte gern
tomatenmark und wenn den knoblauch uns
irgendwas stück sein das so diese werde
zuerst und dann kann ich sie hier
aufkochen lassen und in der zwischenzeit
kümmere ich mich schon mal um das
fleisch innen viel sie hat mit dem was
mitgebracht ihr könnt aber auch ganz
normale hähnchenbrust verwenden
ihnen fehlt einfach ein bisschen
schneller durch da nehme ich jetzt
beweisen stellen weckt und weiß dann
einfach in drei zentimeter lange stücke
schneiden
nicht
[Musik]
die sauce inzwischen schön eingedeckt
die kann ich jetzt aus machen und kann
jetzt hier schon mal sesamöl in meine
pfanne geben und damit das fleisch
angebracht das heißt die kann ich auch
schon mal erhitzen und hier auf dieser
seite des fleisch mit der stärke
vermischen
[Musik]
gibt alles auf mit rohem fleisch und
verbindung haben solltet ihr auf jeden
fall gründlich reinigen
friedman jetzt auch schon kommt das
fleisch rein und wird rundherum
angebraten
[Musik]
das leiste auch versuchsweise an alles
in einer pfanne weil es einfach ein
bisschen zu viel da fällt auf die hitze
immer vor stark runter und die innen
viel es sind wirklich sehr schnell das
heißt einmal rundherum komplett schön
braun anbraten und danach lege ich sie
direkt aus der pfanne in die soße
[Musik]
die letzten aus fertig jetzt kann ich
die soße noch einmal aufkochen lassen so
könnt ihr auch noch mal ganz sichergehen
dass wirklich alle hähnchenteile durch
sind
[Musik]
es hat sich hier ein wechselt raus
schallte ihm heraus dass das ganze ab
kühl und etwa zwei stunden marinieren so
kann das fleisch wirklich die vollen
aromen der soße annehmen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal meine
war projekt brötchen vorbereiten aber
die sandwich brote und alle anderen
staaten richten und dann geht's weiter
halo combat massivsten sein
also ich hätte ja 50 fußbälle facebook
preise fuß 38 cm
damit es hier einmal halbiert das bundes
ganz frisch gebacken deswegen werde ich
jetzt nicht toasten und überbacken
okay okay heute im angebot haben wir das
ist ein café keese
er hat eine so tolle schmelz eigenschaft
das heißt wer das brot zu backen würden
dann wird es richtig toll drauf
schmelzen kost aber mehr beinfreiheit
die zwiebel was ich besonders im
geschmack und ich hatte nur rot dam
wir sind bereits entscheidend woher
kommen die uni wien mit der oliven sind
vom türkischen supermarkt von artikeln
ob gerlach und ich hab die vollen fein
säuberlich vom kern entfernt
weil ich gerne lese keine gurken wie man
vielleicht etwas rappen oder motto ich
bin scharf
händels bayerisches kritische masse dazu
ja und zwar nicht gern was haben im amt
oder sambal olek die hin sambal olek
dann bei rolex da muss ich dazu sagen
mein mann der moral der denkt immer dass
das ein ballon irgendwann was vom globus
ausgelistet werden in kaufbeuren oder ja
das war übrigens wirklich wenig bewegen
es noch 520 euro als nebeneffekt zeit
wir wollen noch ein bisschen besser
keine getränke mir gefallen
bei ernsten es wird man gern denkt man
schon wie geschäftsführer spricht mit
ihren finger in meinem fällt deswegen
immer das haar stoffe reiners aber egal
was mach ich jetzt
das heißt die engelein geschmacksnote
die ganze keine kopie dazu haben jetzt
noch in der zubereitung die gibt's dann
einfach beim nächsten mal die sabotiert
ok ich fand es toll schmeckt echt ne
frage hat die kleine eine
arbeitsgenehmigung ja gehört der laden
sie ist die kutsche films würdig
aber wir fragen jetzt ist und bis zum
nächsten mal das rezept meister
vergessen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir haben ihn wir haben nur 15 cm
gegeben
also falls ihr nachmachen möchte geht
auch sally blog.de da steht noch mal
alles ganz genau
wir werden hier noch ein bisschen spiel
und dem mittel geld zu entlocken
das kommt einer kaffeekasse für das
nächste ice oder so machen wir das also
bis zum nächsten mal fünf tagen noch
luft
das mit diebe versuchen
[Musik]
me
dort also ich hätte gern dass 50 fuß
sandwich keine versprechungen 35 cm
[Gelächter]
kommt frisches kaufsignal ist ein
sparschwein
ich hab gedacht sagt muslims